hello everyone and welcome to another
game of the 2019 riga feed a grand prix
semi-finals it's Alexander Grisha vs.
maxi Marshall a grub so far Maxime was
able to kick out every opponent in the
classical time format I don't I don't
think Maxime reached the hunter Rapids
in any of the previous matchups so let's
see how he does against Alexander Greece
shook this is the second game of the
classical time format and the first game
ended in a draw
so here Grisha has the white pieces and
let's see what happened
Grisha goes for this d4 with Knight to
f6 c4 and the g6 and here well we have
the Kings Indian defense but already an
early age for from Alexander Grisha we
even have a nice photo of this moment
there you have it let me just let me
just open it up here it is sorry about
that
yep here it is thought I'd prepared it
but I didn't but never mind
there we have it nice nice and big so as
you can see h4 is on the board and
Maxine was so confused with this early
age for move that he even took Sasha's a
bottle of water and you know claimed it
as his own as you can see Maxine has two
bottles of water now but that's what
kind of an effect and early age for can
have you know in a serious chess game so
hope you enjoyed that now let's return
to the game also this is a the same move
Veselin Topalov used against onigiri in
the 2016 candidates in moscow that game
ended in a draw but this game is a bit
different with c5 by Grichuk sorry bye
Maksim holograph the same way giri tried
to countertop olives early age 4 in the
candidates 2016 we have d5 and now
basically what we have is a benoni with
with an H for which is not something you
will see very often Maxime continues in
the spirit of the Benoni with b5 well
sort of a nice Banco type gambit see
capture some b5 and now a 6
during a second pond but with III and
III is a new move here the power of
captured on a six again is given in 2016
candidates with 83 now and already and
move six and move six we have a
completely new game which is always very
exciting so Maxime continues Bishop to
g7 with Knight to c3 and now we have
castles both players still reluctant to
waste the tempo capturing on the Queen
side with Knight to f3 by Grisha and now
d6 with a 4 not a 3 sorry about that
with a 4 and Bishop to g4 now and rook
to a3
a very nice forklift and now a character
son b5 with Bishop captures on b5
developing the bishop also that's a lot
of activity for the light-square bishop
and not Knight the a6 with E 4 by Gary
shook and now Knight the be for the
night is now occupying a very nice
square and here already you can see
what's about to happen this pawn is
coming to c4 at some moment this night
from here is gonna control
well the d3 Square and this night here
will join in the action depending on on
what white place but most likely with
something like nice to d7 followed by
Knight to e5 and from there this night
can also join in on the d3 action so
bush of the back to e 2 and now comes
Knight to d7 this night as we already
mentioned eater is coming to e5 or maybe
if c4 is supposed and maybe to c5 and
from there to d3 with castles bye-bye
Grisha and now Queen to b6 the queen is
now coming to b7 rook to e1 and now
Queen - b7 from the Queen now from b7
let's the night come over to the b6
square and also if the center well is
attacked then there also the Queen will
be putting pressure on the e4 square
with Bishop to g5 now attacking the east
7th pawn and now Bishop captures on f3
and here although Grisha can capture
with the bishop it's I don't know do you
want to do this Bishop captures 95
attacks the bishop there should be two
and then c4 and
we get this whole idea that we've
already talked about the both nights now
control the d3 square also the pawn
really helps out and once this knife
comes here it's basically a monster
night and it's gonna be very difficult
for for white to defend this so
aggressive tries a different idea G
captures an f3 strengthening in the
center but it doesn't really change
blacks plan with Knight to e5 now the
Queen also guards these 7 points so you
cannot capture here and here
we've looked f you don't want this c4
and night to d3 to come with an attack
on the rook so rook to f1 and the rook
is on a much safer Square there so c4
maxime continues in the same fashion
that he planned but here gribov says I
think your c4 was a bit premature I'm
just gonna push b3 here attack your pawn
here and what are you gonna play now so
here you have to make a choice here
maxime plays rook F to c8 but there was
also a very interesting move as you can
see the bishop is attacking the knight
on c3 so is Knight captures on f3 and
option here it is an option but after
Bishop captures on f3 and Bishop
captures on c3
you can capture on c4 and the White will
say I'm very happy with this I have a
very strong center I have a past a pawn
that I'm ready to push so I like my
position so Maxine is not interested in
this he just plays rook F to c8 this
rook is now ready to support either the
pushing of this past pawn or if white
captures here then the knight can just
recapture with Bishop back to d2 now not
allowing this tactic anymore with Bishop
captures on c3 but now we have Knight B
to D 3 and now even if this night
doesn't really have any threats at the
moment
it's still a monster night and well you
don't really have a good way of dealing
with it even if you capture once the
knight will recapture and now this
Knight is on a d3 light square you don't
really have a good way of getting rid of
it you'd have to waste 3 moves like
something like 92 2 c1 2 captures but
you know in those 3 moves black will
also get a say in this so after night
beat the d3 with f4 first
grecian wants to get rid of this night
and only then capture on d3 so this
night will not be able to recapture
but here maxime says nope
we're not going to move the night Queen
to b4 and here is where the party is
really getting started turnout the rook
on a3 is under attack if the knight
moves anywhere now with check then the
but then this knight also becomes under
attack as the Queen is attacking it
twice if you capture here then the rook
also will be attacking the knight here
so there are a lot of tactics here and
Grisha has to decide what to do here he
plays nice to be won
he defends the rook and also opens up an
attack against the black Queen here so
what does black play here it's a very
complicated position so what would you
play here really just pause the video
here and try to find a nice move with
black and that is what Maxime did in
this position while I give you a couple
of seconds for those who were able to do
it congratulations you are an excellent
pusher of passed pawns well not yet is
it a past poem but it will be once you
push it so c3 here congratulations to
everyone who found it so what do you
reply here do you capture it do you
capture with the knight do you capture
with the bishop do you play something
else
do you maybe capture the knight on e5
well or all of those are very
interesting options so let's just check
few of them Bishop captures on c3 what
happens here well just rope captures on
c3 and now after Knight captures now not
capturing the rook here but rather
Knight captures on f4 and now it's just
a so superior position for black that
white doesn't even have a move your rook
is still under attack so you should move
it let's say you're okay too you don't
want to put it on this diagonal here but
now Queen captures on c3 and now what do
you play here you have to play something
Queen to h3 followed by Queen to d2 will
be deadly so maybe f3 block the Queen
but then Queen the e3 check now what do
you play here King h1 nice the h5 now
going after the g3 square with chick
look the g1 but now Queen to f4 going
for the capture here and now after
Quinta II one you get Knights the d3 and
here you just don't have anymore good
moves if you capture for example a bunch
of characters you get Queen cap
an f3 would check and after Luke blocks
you get Quinta H richer king did she
want now the bishop comes into the game
Bishop d1 but Bishop d4 checking if one
Queen h1 checking has to go to e2 now
you grab a rook King D 1 or you grab the
other rook and white is just down too
much material on the other hand after
this see to remove you don't have to
capture with the bishop we could also
try to capture with the night but still
Mac seems idea here was not again
capturing drug but Knights the b2 first
you get this night out of the way with
an attack on the Queen and once white
replies let's say Knight b5 he opens up
an attack against your Queen Queen
captures on e4 and white doesn't really
have all that much to do the queen is
under attack here once you move the
Queen you get the knight back to d3 and
now again it's just a very difficult
position to play for white and black
will just be very happy here it's much
better than capturing for example with
the bishop in that position but still
wish of characters here is met with nice
captures on f3 with the check not
something you want to do and now the
problem is you have to go under the mask
of the Queen you can go to h2 so
whatever you play King g2 and this
capture comes with check so it just
loses not not you know pleasant
opposition at all to be in so great joke
did the only thing he had left F
captures on e5 but now night beat night
to be two attacking the Queen Queen to
c2 and only now C captures on d2 we have
Queen captures on b2 and now Queen
captures on e4 there's no rush to
recapture here what is unable to capture
due to the pin so Queen captures on d2
and now rook the c2 and here even though
white black is down a piece he will get
his piece back now the bishop on e2 will
fall and there are a few ways you can
get give up this piece you can place I'm
like Bishop to f3 just try and give it
up there
Grisha tried a different idea Queen to
d3 and of course Maxime had to capture
the bishop with rook captures Queen
captures rook captures and he captures
on d6 with he captures on d6 and now
Knight the d2 attacking the rook rook
captures on h4 there was no
way to save dh4 pawn and now King sorry
not true captors on h4 immediately but
first rook captures in g4 King to h1 and
only now rook captures on h4 with check
without wasting time
King G - now comes rooked the d4
attacking the knight Knight to f3 and
I'm still not going after this capture
and allowing White's to start pushing
his passed pawn but first looked to g4
check King to h3 and now rook back to be
four here
maxime is not interested in grabbing the
d5 pawn and allowing White's to create a
pawn storm on the Queen side so he just
blocks the passports on the Queen side
we have worked to be one preparing to
try and get to this rook out of the game
or if this pawn is attacked another time
then the b3 point is nicely defended so
rook the c8 maxime prepares to bring
this rook into the game King to g2 and
not rook the c3 and now what do you play
here here a nice the g1 was played by
Gary oak getting denied that will weigh
probably going for night Stewie - to
kick away the rooks but also a
possibility here was probably Grisha was
not interested in it was rook to e1 just
giving up the b3 pawn and it's really an
interesting idea to try and give away
the pawn but probably black would go for
something like a rook to g4 check first
and only after King to f1 as now you
lose the night here a knight is better
than the pawn so I'm talking to f1 you
would lose the night but now comes Luke
- eh check bushel blocks and now you
start pushing your passport and there's
really no easy way to prevent the pawn
from cleaning you have to go for
something like rook before and therefore
a6 capture here white really doesn't
care
push pushes a 7 and now you will have to
give up your look for for the Queen
captures captures and you get this
position rook in two points against the
bishop and four points I'll draw an
endgame
so one of the options was actually rook
to e1 here but okay Grisha goes for a
night to g1 with rook to c2 now
preparing to bring the bishop into the
game Bishop to d4 will be an idea
attacking the f2 pawn Knight back to f3
controlling the d4 square but
now look back to g4 with check King f1
and now rook to f4 attacking the knight
so what do you play here King to g2 I
agree should repeats with rook to g4
check King to f1 look to f4 King to g2
but now not rook to g4 and claiming a
draw by threefold but rather g5 just
asking what do you want to play so here
Grisha played rook to f1 he's not
interested in waiting for g4 which where
he would have to move the knight and
then he would lose the f2 pawn but it
also was possible here if you try
something like before you can actually
allow g4 but now you get this very
complicated line with King to g3 where
you either move the rook and lose the g4
pawn on or you move the rook and then
the knight can move so here you would
have to give up the exchange rook
captures now rook captures on f3 g
captures and now you start pushing the
pawn but after rook the b2 black is
black is much better here
for example rook captures Bishop
captures and you start pushing the pawn
but Bishop d4 makes everything work b7
you will prevent the pond from queening
and the bishop will do a very nice job
preventing both of the Queen side points
from queening you just get your King
into the game now maybe grab the D 5
points for pushing her points and win
the game it's a very easy game to win
so what before was one of the options
here although not really a a working one
so rooks the f1 grisha gets ready for g4
so he can move the night but now rook to
g4 once again King to h1 and now rook
the c3 just attacking this night here so
what do you do here here you could try a
lot of things night 2 h2 is a very
interesting idea for example if Knight
to h2 then yes you get rook to h3 and
now the threat is rook to h4 and winning
the night but here white had a very
interesting idea before and so now you
give up your a3 rook for this rook for
example rook captures you get Knight
captures on g4 you lose your queen side
pawns but it's you know you have to do
something Ruby one you to save this one
but now worship the
see three attacks the pawn be five and
then you have to give up the night if
you don't want to lose the past pawn and
so on and so on but black would again be
better here
so Griff tried to look to g1 but it
still doesn't work but that's up to you
to find out feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the winning move
for Maxime for sherrilyn graph in this
position I'll give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent and game player with you know
a lot of rooks on the board and for the
zoo who just want to enjoy the show
rook to f4 wins for black so here again
what do you play here
Knights the h2 was played although nice
the g5 is also an interesting option it
leads the rook captures on f2 and now
the thread is just kicking the night
away and deliver mate here on h3 so
you'd have to probably make some room
room d1 but now rook to c2 and whatever
you play let's say Knight e4 you're just
gonna deliver check King g1 and f5 and
you win the night in the night has no
squares this is taken by the road with
this taken by the pawn sorry this is
taken by the pawn these squares are
taken by the rooks you can't go to g3 or
g5 because rook check just picks up the
night if you go there this is covered by
the bishop and of course lastly but not
leastly
if you capture on d6 Bishop to f8 just
wins the game on the spot
you can't defend the night if you move
the night to lose the rook and so on so
not possible goodness you've tried nice
to h2 but here maxime played rook
captures an F to threatening rook to h3
and well just check mating right here
with rook captures on g5 but here maxime
just played rook c2 c2 and it was in
this position that Alexandria who
resigned the game and well he did it for
good reason because whatever you play
here let's say you don't want to give up
the night you can go Knight g4 but then
you get rook the c1 and it's checkmate
since you just blocked your rook if you
don't move it there you could try
something like rook to age 5 to try and
defend the night but still rook c1 check
you have to block this is mate and any
other move
what can you play let's say you try
something like Knight to f3 try and give
a piece ok black will grab your piece
but you don't have any compensation
you can't start even pushing your pawns
you could start pushing a5 but doesn't
really do that much black ball black
will have everything you know in order
you'll play King f8 Bushell d4 just
block the pawns and it's easily winning
em again for black
so of course Greek knows this and after
Luke c2 c2 he resigned the game and this
means that he was just knocked out of
the feeder grand prix semi-final by
Maxime holograph who will meet don't
want to spoil anything for you if you're
not interested but he will meet share my
media of who has knocked out Wesley so
ordered the semi-final we already saw
the game destructor mama D r1 we said
that Wesley has a chance to get back
into the game with the white pieces but
mama Dara was able to hold Wesley to a
draw and then we will see tomorrow I
don't think there's a rest day tomorrow
we will see Roger Mamedov versus Maxime
for sherrilyn Grove in the finals of the
feeder Grand Prix being held in in Riga
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Scott Levesque
and Christopher dick for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it today's video came a
little bit late but my air conditioning
is not working and I really whom wasn't
able to record before as it was really
just too hot in my apartment so sorry
about that but yeah yeah like I said I
do hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
y'all for watching and I will see you
soon continuing the Capablanca saga
checking up the finals of the Fida grand
prix checking up on your suggestions and
so on and so on
thank y'all I will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day